Armelle un journal américain le Wall
Street Journal de son côté lui il a
retracé les dernières heures le dernier
jour de yefghani prigogi et ses riches
d'enseignement oui alors c'est la presse
américaine qui s'est focalisé sur sur
toute la trajectoire du
qui s'est rendu compte que il était
effectivement en Afrique il avait fait
une vidéo on l'avait vu au sel on
l'avait vu avec le désert derrière et
donc du coup en pouvant que il y était
allé alors il n'était pas allé dans au
début dans la zone sahélienne il était
dans une zone qui était beaucoup plus
boisée qui est la Centrafrique il est
allé à Bangui où il a rencontré le
président de la Centrafrique il l'aurait
assuré de son soutien quoi qu'il arrive
il aurait eu aussi un échange avec des
gens de chez Wagner qui arrivaient du
Soudan et qui avait des paiements à lui
fournir et qui donc qui aurait fourni de
l'or jusque là ce qui est très
traditionnel puisque lorsque les il y a
des opérations ainsi des milices russes
sur ce type de pays bien qu'elle
financer et elles le sont par
l'extraction de minerais entre autres
donc l'or a été effectivement une des
grandes richesses de prix gaugines et
puis derrière il est parti au Mali et
ensuite il est il s'est envolé et il
s'est envolé ça c'est assez surprenant
quand même parce qu'il s'est envolé avec
tout le staff de Wagner c'est à dire
avec son numéro 2 et avec on a appris
ensuite le logisticien de Wagner qui
sont effectivement ceux qui sont portés
disparus généralement on peut s'attendre
à ce que ces individus et quand même
plus j'allais dire
d'attention en ayant peut-être plusieurs
avions on peut peut-être plus de
discrétion et dans le même temps le Wall
Street Journal rappelle que tout ça est
concomissant avec une visite en Libye
qui est celle du vice-ministre de la
Défense russe à afta et que le
vice-ministre la Défense russe assure
juste la veille en fait ou le l'avion ne
sera crasher de Prigogine assure de son
soutien la Libye
et maréchal Haftar quoi qu'il arrive
même si effectivement il n'y a plus
Wagner il ne prononce pas ces mots-là
mais il est là pour dire que quoi qu'il
arrive il y aura l'aide russe mais cette
fois-ci du gouvernement russe et ce qui
montrait un peu la différence aussi
évidemment avec une milice merci
beaucoup Armelle pour ses analyses Armel
sharing notre chroniqueuse international
ici à France 24